y el termómetro en el porche delantero marcaba -40 grados
y no se molesten en preguntar si son grados Celsius o Fahrenheit,
-40 es donde confluyen ambas escalas.
Hacía mucho frío.
Y mientras estaba en el porche delantero mirando en mis bolsillos,
me di cuenta de que no tenía las llaves.
De hecho, podía ver por la ventana
que estaban en la mesa del comedor, donde las había dejado.
Así que rápido intenté abrir todas las otras puertas y ventanas,
y todas estaban bien cerradas.
Pensé en llamar a un cerrajero, al menos tenía mi celular,
pero a la medianoche, un cerrajero podría tardar mucho tiempo en llegar,
y hacía frío.
No podía volver a casa de mi amigo de Jeff para pasar noche
pues tenía un vuelo temprano a Europa a la mañana siguiente,
y precisaba de mi pasaporte y mi maleta.
Así que, desesperado y helado,
encontré una piedra grande y con ella rompí la ventana del sótano,
tras limpiar los fragmentos de vidrio,
me arrastré por ella,
encontré un pedazo de cartón y lo puse en la apertura,
pensando que por la mañana, camino al aeropuerto,
llamaría a mi contratista para pedirle que lo arreglara.
Resultaría caro,
pero seguro que no más caro que un cerrajero a media noche,
así que pensé, que a pesar de las circunstancias, salía bien parado.
Soy neurólogo de profesión
y sé un poco acerca de cómo funciona el cerebro bajo estrés.
Libera cortisol que aumenta el ritmo cardíaco,
modula los niveles de adrenalina
y nubla el pensamiento.
A la mañana siguiente,
cuando me desperté con falta de sueño,
preocupado por el agujero en la ventana,
por mi nota mental de llamar a mi contratista,
por las bajas temperaturas,
y por las reuniones que tendría la siguiente semana en Europa,
y con todo el cortisol en el cerebro,
mi pensamiento estaba nublado,
pero no sabía que estaba nublado porque mi pensamiento estaba nublado.
(Risas)
Y cuando llegué al mostrador de facturación en el aeropuerto,
me di cuenta de que no tenía mi pasaporte.
(Risas)
Así que corrí a casa en la nieve y el hielo, 40 minutos,
agarré mi pasaporte y volví al aeropuerto.
Lo hice justo a tiempo,
pero habían dado mi asiento a otra persona,
así que me quedé atrapado en la parte trasera del avión, al lado de los baños,
en un asiento que no se reclinaba en un vuelo de ocho horas.
Bueno, tuve mucho tiempo para pensar en esas 8 horas sin dormir.
(Risas)
Y empecé a preguntarme, si había algo que pudiera hacer,
sistemas que pudiera poner en su lugar,
que eviten que sucedan cosas malas.
O al menos, si suceden cosas malas,
que minimicen la probabilidad de que sea una catástrofe total.
Así que me puse a pensar en eso,
pero hasta un mes después mis pensamientos no cristalizaron.
Estaba cenando con mi colega Danny Kahneman, ganador del Premio Nobel,
y un poco avergonzado le hablé de que rompí la ventana,
y, de que había olvidado mi pasaporte,
y Danny compartió conmigo
que había estado practicando algo llamado retrospectiva prospectiva.
(Risas)
Es algo que él había aprendido del psicólogo Gary Klein,
quien había escrito de esto unos años antes,
conocido también como el premortem.
Todos saben lo que es el postmortem.
Cada vez que hay un desastre,
un equipo de expertos viene y trata de averiguar lo que salió mal, ¿sí?
En el premortem, como explica Danny,
uno mira adelante e intenta averiguar todas las cosas que podrían salir mal,
a continuación, intenta averiguar qué puede hacer
para evitar que las cosas sucedan o para minimizar el daño.
Así que de lo que quiero hablar con Uds. es de algunas cosas
que podemos hacer en la forma de una premortem.
Algunos de ellas son evidentes, otras no son tan evidentes.
Voy a empezar con las obvias.
En la casa, designar un lugar para las cosas que se pierden fácilmente.
Esto suena de sentido común y lo es,
pero hay mucha ciencia que apoya esta tesis,
basándose en cómo funciona nuestra memoria espacial.
Hay una estructura en el cerebro llamada hipocampo,
que ha evolucionado a lo largo de miles de años,
para hacer un seguimiento de la ubicación de las cosas importantes,
donde está el bien, donde están los peces,
que ubica los árboles frutales,
donde viven las tribus amigas y enemigas.
El hipocampo es la parte del cerebro
que se agranda en los taxistas de Londres.
Es la parte del cerebro que permite a las ardillas encontrar sus nueces.
Y si se preguntan si alguien realmente hizo el experimento,
cortaron el sentido olfativo de las ardillas
y aún así podían encontrar sus nueces.
Ellas no usaban el olfato, sino el hipocampo,
ese mecanismo muy evolucionado del cerebro para encontrar cosas.
Pero es realmente bueno para cosas que no se mueven mucho,
no tan bueno para cosas que se mueven mucho.
Esta es la razón para perder llaves del auto, gafas de lectura y pasaportes.
Así que en casa designen un lugar para las llaves,
un gancho junto a la puerta, tal vez un plato decorativo.
Para su pasaporte, un cajón en particular.
Para sus gafas de lectura, una mesita en particular.
Si designan un lugar y son escrupulosos con ello
sus cosas siempre estarán ahí cuando las busquen.
¿Qué pasa con los viajes?
Tomen con el celular una foto de sus tarjetas de crédito,
licencia de conducir, pasaporte,
envíenselo por correo a sí mismos para que estén en la nube.
Si estas cosas se pierden o las roban, esto puede facilitar la sustitución.
Estas son algunas de las cosas más obvias.
Recuerden, cuando se está bajo estrés, el cerebro libera cortisol.
El cortisol es tóxico y enturbia el pensamiento.
Así que parte de la práctica premortem
es reconocer que bajo estrés no estaremos en el mejor momento,
y hay que poner los sistemas en su sitio.
Y hay quizás no más estresante situación
que cuando uno se enfrenta ante una decisión médica.
Y en algún momento, todos estaremos en esa situación,
de tener que tomar una decisión muy importante
sobre el futuro de nuestra atención médica o la de un ser querido,
para ayudarles con una decisión.
Y por eso quiero hablar de eso.
Y hablaré de una afección médica muy particular.
Pero esto se erige como un proxy para toda toma de decisiones médicas,
y de hecho para la toma de decisiones financieras y de decisiones sociales,
cualquier tipo de decisión que hay que tomar
de la que se beneficiarían una evaluación racional de los hechos.
Así que supongamos que van al médico y el médico dice:
"He recibido el resultado del laboratorio y el colesterol está un poco alto".
Todos saben que el colesterol alto
se asocia con un mayor riesgo de enfermedades cardiovasculares,
ataque al corazón, derrame cerebral.
Así que uno está pensando que
tener el colesterol alto no es lo mejor,
entonces el médico dice: "Me gustaría recetarle un medicamento
que le ayudará a reducir el colesterol, una estatina".
Y quizá uno ya ha oído hablar de las estatinas,
y sabe que es uno de los medicamentos más recetados
en el mundo hoy.
Incluso es probable que uno conozca a personas que los toman.
Así uno piensa: "¡Sí, recéteme la estatina!"
Pero hay una pregunta que se debe hacer entonces,
una estadística que se debe pedir
de la que la mayoría de los médicos no quieren hablar,
y las compañías farmacéuticas incluso menos.
Es para el NNT, el número necesario a tratar.
Y, ¿qué es esto, el NNT?
Es el número de personas que deben tomar un medicamento
o someterse a una cirugía en cualquier procedimiento médico
antes de que se ayude a una persona.
Y debe pensar ¿qué tipo de estadística descerebrada es esa?
El número debe ser uno.
Mi médico no me recetaría algo
si no fuera a ayudarme.
Pero, en realidad, la práctica médica no funciona así.
Y no es culpa del médico,
y si es culpa de alguien, es de los científicos como yo.
No hemos entendido muy bien los mecanismos subyacentes.
Pero las estimaciones de GlaxoSmithKline
de que el 90 % de los fármacos funciona solo del 30 al 50 % de las personas.
Así que el número necesario a tratar la estatina más ampliamente recetado,
¿cuál creen que es?
¿Cuántas personas tienen que tomarlo antes de que ayude a una persona?
300.
Esto según la investigación
de los investigadores cínicos Jerome Groopman y Pamela Hartzband,
confirmado de forma independiente por Bloomberg.com.
Yo mismo exploré los números.
300 personas tienen que tomar el medicamento durante un año
antes de evitar un solo ataque de corazón, derrame cerebral u otro evento adverso.
Ahora quizá piensen:
"Bueno, 1 probabilidad en 300 de bajar mi colesterol.
¿Por qué no, doctor? Deme la receta de todos modos".
Pero entonces uno se debe preguntar por una estadística más,
y es, "Hábleme de los efectos secundarios". ¿Sí?
Para este medicamento en particular,
los efectos secundarios se producen en el 5 % de los pacientes.
Y esos incluyen cosas terribles:
debilitante dolor muscular y articular, dolor gastrointestinal,
pero ahora piensan: "El 5 %
no es muy probable que me pase a mí,
aún así tomaré la medicina".
Pero un momento,
recuerden que bajo estrés no piensan con claridad.
Así que piensen cómo asimilaran esto con el tiempo,
así que no tienen que fabricar la cadena de razonamiento en el acto.
300 personas toman el fármaco, ¿no? A una persona le ha ayudado,
5 % de los 300 tienen efectos secundarios,
eso son 15 personas.
Uno tiene 15 veces más probabilidades de salir perjudicado por el fármaco
de que te ayude el medicamento.
No digo que deban o no tomar la estatina.
Solo digo que deben tener esta conversación con su médico.
La ética médica lo requiere,
es parte del principio de consentimiento informado.
Tenemos derecho a tener acceso a este tipo de información
para iniciar la conversación sobre de si uno quiere asumir los riesgos o no.
Quizá están pensando que
he lanzado este número en el aire por el valor del choque,
pero en realidad este número necesario a tratar es bastante típico.
Para la cirugía que más se realiza en los hombres mayores de 50,
extirpación de la próstata por cáncer,
el número necesario a tratar es de 49.
Así es, 49 cirugías por una persona a la que ha ayudado.
Y los efectos secundarios en ese caso, se producen en el 50 % de los pacientes.
Esos incluyen la impotencia o disfunción eréctil,
incontinencia urinaria, lagrimeo rectal,
incontinencia fecal.
Y si se tiene suerte y se es uno de ese 50 %
los efectos solo durarán un año o dos.
Así que la idea de la premortem es pensar antes de tiempo
las preguntas que uno puede plantear
que impulsarán la conversación hacia adelante.
Uds. no tienen por qué fabricar todo esto en el acto.
Y también quieren pensar en la calidad de vida.
Debido a que se tiene una opción muchas veces,
¿quieren una vida más corta libre de dolor,
o una vida más larga que podría tener mucho dolor hacia el final?
Estas son las cosas de las que hablan y piensan de ahora,
con su familia y sus seres queridos.
Pueden cambiar de opinión en el calor del momento,
pero al menos que uno esté entrenado en este tipo de pensamiento.
Recuerden, nuestro cerebro libera cortisol bajo estrés,
y una de las cosas que sucede en ese momento
es que se apagan un montón de sistemas.
Hay una razón evolutiva para esto.
Cara a cara con un depredador, no es necesario el sistema digestivo,
o la libido o el sistema inmunológico,
porque si el cuerpo está gastando el metabolismo en esas cosas,
no reacciona con rapidez.
Podrían llegar a ser el almuerzo de los leones, así que nada de eso importa.
Desafortunadamente,
una de las cosas que se va por la ventana durante esos momentos de estrés
es el pensamiento lógico racional,
como Danny Kahneman y sus colegas han demostrado.
Así que tenemos que entrenarnos para pensar en el futuro
a este tipo de situaciones.
Creo que lo importante aquí es reconocer que todos somos defectuosos.
Todos vamos a fallar de vez en cuando.
La idea es pensar en el futuro cómo podrían ser esos fallos,
para poner los sistemas en el lugar que le ayudará a minimizar el daño,
o para evitar que las cosas malas sucedan en el primer lugar.
Rebobinando a la noche de nieve en Montreal,
cuando regresé de mi viaje,
mi contratista me instaló una cerradura de combinación junto a la puerta,
con una llave de la puerta de entrada en el mismo, una forma fácil de recordarlo.
Y tengo que admitir que
todavía tengo montones de cartas que no he ordenado,
y montones de mensajes de correo que no he leído.
Así que no soy muy organizado,
pero veo la organización como un proceso gradual,
y lo estoy logrando.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)